you're always like on top of pop culture
you're always and i love your
impressions and i love it listen it's
growing and so what do people do now you
said you're you're um it's not only fans
but how do they get to whatever you're a
funny fans
youtube.com kyle dunnigan is what i'm
trying to get so so what what kyle's
doing now and i think this is brilliant
because you've always been on the cusp
technically of how people are doing it
he has a private youtube i think it's a
monthly fee right oh yeah i do like a
weekly free show on thursday it's like a
live kind of sketch i'm gonna watch it
yeah
is that the one i was on
yes you were on an early one that was
mainly just craig this is like all
different characters like alec hosted
last week it's kind of hosted and then i
love the news thing with your neighbor
oh yeah yes what is that mr nichols
thing yeah that was yeah who is that
that's my friend john bush he actually
helps write and stuff this show that we
do and you have a child on it too well
yeah there's a baby app this girl
jessica
oh she's done this oh that's the same
jessica that was on yes exactly we just
put a baby app on her face what's your
favorite what's your favorite character
to do uh
maybe i like dealing like jeff goldblum
i like baldwin put up the jeff goldblum
on instagram thank you go down a little
bit there's a jeff goldblum
how many have you done all together
hundreds hundreds oh my god yeah do you
post daily uh no i try to do at least
um a new video a week but they actually
take a long time sketches like are they
on tick tock too or just uh just
starting to put them on tech talk but um
but isn't it important why there's
that's jeff i think that's not a i think
it's another one of those things oh it's
another promo
and then so how do they get they go to
youtube uh kyle donaghy yeah youtube.com
backshot's kyle dynas
and what are you charging about well do
they get special do they get material
that nobody else can see yeah there's
like a behind the scenes and there's a
podcast um
there's a podcast uh every weekly
podcast and behind the scenes and then
you know the show's free but then
there's like extras if you want this is
uh jeff goldblum opening a gift yeah
that was given to him from sylvester
stallone
okay here we go
yes hello there um
i have the
mystery prize here
uh um
shaking it we still can't tell what it
is
that's why you gotta open it there
it is uh
light
ish uh
but if i was a miniature person would it
would be quite heavy for me to carry
around
uh
jeff we don't have a lot of time here
time what is that we do do do we even
know what it is it's uh ethereal it's uh
it's incongruent it's a
mysterious uh but also very familiar he
just like he likes to savor every moment
of life
but we have a big show we'll get back to
him he's got to be done by now right
yeah
hey jeff where are we with this
there's uses for this even without
opening there's still i could have a
little rest
here
it is more i don't know i'm keep saying
the same thing over and over it's better
than anything it makes me every time i
cannot wait to get on my phone i have
not gotten on my phone or where i
haven't gone to instagram and watch
something even if you're it's not a new
post every day i get a laugh from you
yeah that's what i watch obviously
you're not the only one he's getting
tons of views
you do stand up right yeah i do yeah i
started use this in your standpoint you
know i just started to put impressions
in my stand-up
video just bring the video i actually do
that actually there yeah there's a um
there's a clip i put a screen up like
this
um and i project the face onto it i sit
with a computer it's a section of my
stand-up back but it's very you know
early formed i'll do like a game with
the audiences you know biden or
something like that and then i can
stream people in
like so go ahead you should do on your
dating apps if you want to get no i'm
serious you should put like they think
they're going out with jeff goldblum or
alex baldwin and you'll see who you get
i i um maybe it'll be a step okay
[Music]